jetzt also wie gesagt der
tagesordnungspunkt zur lage an den
flughäfen in deutschland insbesondere zu
dem problem der fachkräftegewinnung und
davor die union ihr ein sofortprogramm
zur arbeits und fachkräftegewinnung und
bis das soweit ist muss noch mal kurz
reinhören eben das was ihr vom markt war
es die bundestags-vizepräsidentin gerade
zur tagesordnung erläutert da scheint es
noch einen weiteren zusatzpunkt zu geben
gehören am besten mal direktheit 20 67
zu dem antrag auf genehmigung zum
vollzug gerichtlicher durchsuchung und
beschlagnahme der
ausschuss empfiehlt die genehmigung zu
erteilen wer stimmt für diese
beschlussempfehlung
das ist das gesamte haus wer stimmt
dagegen
enthaltungen gibt es keine dann ist die
beschlussempfehlung angenommen ich rufe
auf den zusatzpunkt 11 die beratung des
antrags der fraktion der cdu/csu mit dem
titel chaos an den flughäfen beseitigen
und sofortprogramm zur arbeits und
fachkräftegewinnung
auflegen für die aussprache ist eine
dauer von
68 minuten vorgesehen ich bitte die
damen und herren die der debatte folgen
wollen die plätze jetzt einzunehmen und
diejenigen wieder debatte nicht folgen
wollen im plenarsaal zu verlassen oder
in den hinteren reihen platz zu nehmen
und ich eröffne die aussprache und ich
hatte das wort dem kollegen mark die
addax cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
deutschland steht in der warteschlange
nach jahrzehntelangem aufschwung
erfahren wir nun wirtschaftlichen
stillstand und für die bürgerinnen und
bürger heißt das vor allem warten warten
am check-in am flughafen warten auf
handwerkerinnen und handwerker warten
auf den zug am bahnhof die menschen in
unserem land merken den fachkräftemangel
jeden tag spätestens die langen
schlangen an den flughäfen hätten der
bundesregierung doch klar machen müssen
jetzt braucht es eine fachkräfte
strategie
doch hierauf müssen
doch hier aufrissen liebe frau müller
gemmeke doch auch hierauf müssen die
bürgerinnen und bürger leider warten
bezeichnet ist es auch keine von der
bundesregierung kein minister heil kein
minister wissing und keine ministerin
leserin ist da einfach nur schade schade
der fachkräftemangel
hallo herr wissing dann habe ich die
übersehen welche
dann haben wir dann entschuldige ich
mich auch da dafür schön dass der
minister wissen da ist dankeschön
der fachkräftemangel kommt zu einer zeit
in der die menschen in unserem land
sowieso schon führt mit vielen krisen zu
kämpfen haben und ihren wohlstand in
gefahr sehen inflation steigende
staatsverschuldung
lieferengpässe und der angriffskrieg von
putin auf die ukraine und der
fachkräftemangel
verstärkt all diese krisen fehlende
fachkräfte treiben die preise weiter in
die höhe fehlende fachkräfte sorgen für
lieferverzögerungen da diese in den
häfen flughäfen und in der logistik
vielen und fehlende fachkräfte bremsen
unsere wirtschaft aus und nun kommt
hinzu dass der fachkräftemangel auch
noch den urlaub sommer ins wasser fallen
lässt auf den menschen in unserem land
seit zwei jahren in der pandemie
gewartet haben deutschland steckt im
reisechaos meine damen und herren
endlose schlangen verpasste flüge
gestrichen flug und zugverbindungen
allein in diesem monat hat die lufthansa
angekündigt 900 flüge zu streichen
an deutschen flughäfen fielen über
7200 fachkraft die bundesregierung plant
nur kurzfristig arbeitskräfte aus der
türkei zu holen um engpässe zu schließen
doch das ist nur ein tropfen auf dem
heißen stein diese maßnahmen sind
kurzfristig nicht nachhaltig und
betreffen nur eine branche
dabei wissen wir schon jetzt
das ist langfristig mehr zuwanderung
braucht nämlich im schnitt 400.000
menschen pro jahr denn alleine bis 2030
wird es in deutschland fast vier
millionen weniger personen im
erwerbsalter geben doch wie in allen
anderen bereichen schafft die
bundesregierung auch beim thema
fachkräfte ein kompetenz chaos mal ein
vorschlag aus dem innenministerium mal
eine idee von minister wissing ein
papier des arbeitsministers liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir können uns das nicht mehr leisten
wir brauchen eine fachkräfte strategie
aus einem guss und wir brauchen die
jetzt
folgende fragen beschäftigen die
menschen auch wie können wir den drei
millionen arbeitslosen in unserem land
eine chance geben wie schaffen wir es
dass mehr fachkräfte aus dem ausland zu
uns nach deutschland kommt für all diese
fragen hat die bundesregierung kein
konzept sie schafft leber nahezu alle
hartz iv sanktionen ab und stoppte damit
das prinzip fordern und fördern schade
als union ist komme ich gerne auf die 16
jahre zu sprechen alt union jetzt haben
sie mal genau zu als union haben wir
einen fußabdruck hinterlassen in der
letzten bundesregierung haben wir
einfach kräfte einwanderungsgesetz dafür
die weichen gestellt jetzt können sie
mit diesem gesetz arbeiten aber es kommt
keine vorschläge von ihm ich möchte
vorschläge von ihnen wissen dass
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetze großen
koalition war ein großer fußabdruck und
von ihnen kommt nichts also kann denn
sie jetzt die menschen haben in diesem
land keine zeit wir brauchen eine
fachkräfte strategie die cdu gearbeitet
gerne mit aber sie müssen liefern
dankeschön
[Applaus]
und der nächste redner ist hakan demir
spd-fraktion
[Applaus]
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen
kollegen vor 50 jahren kam eine gewisse
person namens ibrahim demir nach
deutschland als sogenannter gastarbeiter
er hat mit seinen kolleginnen und
kollegen straßen und häuser gebaut und
damit haben sie zusammen unser land zu
dem gemacht was es heute ist und die
geschichte meines großvaters wiederholt
sich in wirtschaftlich starken ländern
wie in deutschland fehlen arbeitskräfte
dabei bremst der mangel an
arbeitskräften die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung
menschen aus anderen ländern sind bereit
kurzfristig oder länger hier zu bleiben
der aktuelle engpass in der
luftfahrtbranche greift tief in den
alltag der menschen ein
5.500 arbeitskräfte fehlen beim
bodenpersonal
lange schlangen flugausfälle all das
erleben wir gerade an deutschen
flughäfen und jeder von uns der für sich
und seine familie einen urlaub plant
vielleicht lange darauf gespart hat weiß
wie frustrierend flugausfälle sein
können deshalb ist es natürlich richtig
dass die bundesregierung
kurzfristig arbeitskräfte aus der türkei
an wird dank der global zustimmung der
bundesagentur für arbeit und
beschleunigter visa verfahren wird die
anwerbung auch unbürokratisch gehandhabt
außerdem geschah ohne sozialdumping bei
unternehmen die tarifverträge an werden
anwenden herrscht tarifbindung bei allen
anderen ein erhöhter mindestlohn von 14
eur 25 plus zuschläge um niedrige löhne
und schlechte arbeitsbedingungen zu
verhindern
und wir organisieren die anwerbung ohne
sicherheitsstandards abzusenken die im
luftfahrt gesetz vorgesehene
zuverlässigkeitsprüfung findet regulär
statt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der union deshalb läuft ihr antrag an
dieser stelle auch ins leere denn
erfordert etwas das die bundesregierung
sowie so macht
die generelle erleichterung der
arbeitskräfte einwanderung kommt in den
vorgeschlagenen maßnahmen auch von ihnen
nicht vor also ich hab jetzt keine
lösungsvorschläge
gehört mehr noch die bundesregierung hat
jetzt gestern auf den weg gebracht ein
chancen aufenthaltsrecht wir schaffen
bleibeperspektive für die menschen die
hier angekommen sind die ein teil dieser
gesellschaft geworden sind und jetzt
raten sie mal wer dagegen ist die union
aber zurück zur einwanderung die
aktuelle situation
legt auch ein zentrales missverständnis
der einwanderungspolitik der letzten
jahre offen dass legale einwanderung nur
ein thema für hochqualifizierte sein das
erleben wir gerade in der pflege in der
hotelbranche im sicherheitsgewerbe ist
er lebe ist wenn ich mit gastronomen und
gastronomen in meinem wahlkreis neukölln
spreche wir dürfen uns deshalb nicht nur
darauf beschränken den kurzfristigen
mangel in der flugbranche in den blick
zu nehmen wir brauchen stattdessen
grundlegende reformen in unserem ein
wohnungs system vor allem weil es auch
in den anderen bronze die pflege
gastronomie und handwerk an menschen
fehlt hierzu einige ideen die westbalkan
regelung ist eine der
fortschrittlichsten regelung im
deutschen einwanderungsrecht weil sie
zum beispiel ein arbeitsplatzangebot für
das es keine geeigneten kandidaten
kandidaten deutschland gibt zur
voraussetzung macht die einwanderung ist
aber aktuell auf 25.000 pro jahr
gedeckelt wir könnten uns überlegen
diese deckelung beispielsweise anzuheben
aber vielleicht sollten wir auch darüber
nachdenken ob wir die westbalkan
regelung auch auf andere länder
erweitern unser ein bonussystem muss für
menschen aller qualifikationsniveaus
offen sein für hochqualifizierte
menschen mit ersparnissen ist
deutschland bereits eines der
fortschrittlichsten ein wohnungs länder
weltweit aber für menschen die diese
qualifikation nicht nachweisen können
und die aber teils lange berufserfahrung
haben oder bereits sind in branchen zu
arbeiten in denen in deutschland
arbeitskräfte fehlen ist unser ein
währungssystem noch nicht ausgelegt
deshalb wollen wir mit einem
punktesystem nach steuern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
brian d mir hätte heute kaum chancen
nach deutschland einzureisen
mein großvater hatte den mut zu kommen
und deutschland hatte den willen
menschen aufzunehmen mit den erfahrungen
der letzten mindestens 50 jahren müssen
wir diesen willen erneuern ein neues
fachkräfte ein weiteres gesetz auf den
weg bringen und dabei auch menschen wie
beim im blick behalten dankeschön
jörg brandes auf die fraktion ist ja
nichts gegen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten kollegen kollegen es ist schon
erstaunlich wie sie schaffen wirklich
jedes thema oder jedes thema dafür zu
nutzen um ihre migrations sucht zu
befriedigen
der personalnotstand und die damit
verbundenen einschränkungen für den
luftverkehr fassen die gesamtsituation
unseres landes perfekt zusammen arbeiten
scheint sich für viele nicht mehr zu
lohnen und was früher in deutschland
selbstverständlich war und funktioniert
hatte funktioniert heute nicht mehr dass
die menschen aus ihren jobs an den
flughäfen flüchten ist allein auf das
regierungsversagen der jetzigen und der
vorgängerregierung zurückzuführen
[Applaus]
corona history luftverkehrs feindliche
politik verbot von inlands früh das sind
grüne zutaten für dieses flughafen chaos
was jetzt ansteht statt der luftfahrt
eine sichere planungs perspektive zu
bieten bereiten unsere und karbon phobie
leiden politiker die wirtschaft und die
bürger schon auf die neuen
einschränkungen im herbst vor
wohlgemerkt als einzige westliche
industrienationen wie wollen sie da
erwarten dass tausende ehemalige
mitarbeiter die inzwischen einen anderen
job in vermeintlich sicheren branchen
gefunden haben unter diesen umständen
wieder zurück an die flughafen kommen
das ist eine illusion aber wie ich sehe
haben sie das ja auch gar nicht so
geplant das chaos an den flughäfen haben
sie definitiv zu verantworten für die
sicherheitskontrollen von passagieren
und handgepäck sind nicht die airlines
und flughäfen verantwortlich sondern die
bundespolizei
vor monaten wie sich frau feser und der
innenministerium in einem an sie
gerichteten schreiben auf die nun real
gewordenen zustände hin es passierte
damals nichts nichts außer
beschwichtigung und trotz aller
warnungen durch die
bundespolizeigewerkschaft werden durch
die sicherheitskontrollen übrigens ein
teilbereich der terrorbekämpfung die
wurden an private sicherheitsfirmen
ausgelagert wird die terrorabwehr an
flughäfen weil durch mindestlöhne und
durch türkische gastarbeiter
durchgeführt das sind absurde ideen aus
der denkfabrik von frau faeser
das ist sinn wirklich für eine
innenministerin für die der kampf gegen
rechts und die bespitzelung von
regierungskritikern höhere priorität hat
als die bekämpfung des islamistischen
extremismus
sehr geehrte bundesregierung
warum nehmen sie diese herausforderungen
nicht einfach mal als anlass aus den 900
17.000 langzeitarbeitslosen vielleicht
1000 für die gepäckabfertigung zu finden
stattdessen befriedigen sie mal wieder
genüsslich ihre migrations sucht und
heizen das internationale lohndumping
weiter an
stocken sie endlich
stoppen sie endlich die bundespolizei
auf damit sie ihren hoheitsaufgaben
nachkommen kann wir haben es bereits
schon in den haushaltsberatungen
gefordert geben wir boden dienstleistern
und flugpersonal eine langfristige
perspektive
studien beweisen doch das flugreisen nie
ein pandemie herd waren hören sie auf
die nächsten corona horror märchen hier
zu verbreiten erhalten sie die luftfahrt
und darunter lassen sie es zukünftig den
geschundenen bürger nicht nur haare
sondern rapunzels komplette perücke in
die urlaubs suppe zu schmeißen der
bürger
der bürger hat verdient und zwar auch
mal einen urlaub nicht nur flug urlaub
sondern vor allem urlaub von ihnen und
ihren zukunfts feindlichen und bereits
feindlichen politik ansetzen vielen dank
meine damen und herren
dirk brandes aus der idee fraktion und
das bringt mich darauf dass ich ihnen
noch schuldig bin ihn zu erläutern der
zusatzpunkt der wir vorhin nicht
hinreichend erklären konnten jedenfalls
nicht so wie wir uns das gerne wünschen
ist ging um eine beschlussempfehlung des
ausschusses für wahlprüfung immunität
und geschäftsordnung
und zwar ging es konkret um einen antrag
auf genehmigung zum vollzug
gerichtlicher durchsuchung und
beschlagnahme der regel wird das mit den
worten gefasst aufhebung der immunität
und die zwischen wissen wir auch um wen
es geht nämlich den abgeordneten stefan
tutschka aus der afg fraktion wir gucken
zurück in die debatte zum antrag der cdu
csu fraktion chaos an den flughäfen
arbeitskräfte gewinnen unterstrich beate
müller gemmeke aus der fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen
noch mehr personal dem flughafen
verloren weil das nicht zu schaffen ist
und weil so ein stress krank macht auch
das ist ein desaster und nicht
akzeptabel
und dieses desaster kommt wiederum nicht
unerwartet sondern mit ansage an den
flughäfen wurden in zeiten von tottenham
ihre 16 jahre ist okay aber ich rede
jetzt über die zeit von corona wo die
flug wo die flughäfen viel zu viel
personal abgebaut haben trotz
rettungsschirm und trotz
kurzarbeitergeld jetzt fehlen diese
leute und da stellt sich wirklich die
frage warum haben die verantwortlichen
eigentlich nicht ihren job gemacht der
mangel an arbeitskräften bei absehbar
vorausschauendes und
verantwortungsvolles handeln sieht
anders aus
außerdem außerdem sind die probleme im
flughafenbereich schon lange bekannt
waren die beschäftigten früher mal alle
bei den airlines angestellt sind sie
schon lange in zug unternehmen
outgesourced häufig ohne mitbestimmung
ohne tarifbindung
betriebsräte berichten schon länger dass
der fachkräftemangel
durch die schlechten arbeitsbedingungen
entsteht und eben nicht durch fehlende
art bewerberinnen in der kernsegment
muss hier schnell ganz schnell viel
verändert werden notwendig sind dringend
bessere arbeitsbedingungen und bessere
löhne
und jetzt müssen ausländische
arbeitskräfte kurzfristig aushelfen
obwohl wir grüne eigentlich nicht wollen
dass arbeitskräfte nur punktuell und
befristet einwandern wir wollen
stattdessen ein paradigmenwechsel bei
der einwanderungspolitik das bedeutet
mehr gezielte zuwanderung ermöglichen
hürden abbauen und qualifikationen
leichter anerkennen diese konsequente
einwanderungspolitik haben sie
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
jahrelang verhindert und jetzt haben wir
die situation dass in vielen branchen
jetzt haben wir die situation dass in
vielen branchen fach und auch
arbeitskräfte fehlen und dafür tragen
sie auch verantwortung und da hilft auch
ihr antrag heute kein stück weiter
es ist es ist gut dass jetzt schnell
eine lösung mit arbeitskräften aus dem
ausland kommt wichtig ist aber dass
nicht wieder prekärer beschäftigung
entsteht die arbeitskräfte müssen
tariflich bezahlt und auch
menschenwürdig untergebracht werden das
muss jetzt auch wirklich um die
schutzschirms und dafür trägt die
luftfahrtbranche die verantwortung und
das werden da werden wir auch genau
hinschauen vielen dank
und ich teile das wort pascal mal zur
fraktion die linke
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren denn aktuell
hunderttausende urlauberinnen und
urlauber an deutschen flughäfen
stundenlang auf ihre abfertigung warten
müssen oder flug in den wohlverdienten
urlaub wegen personalmangel kurzfristig
gestrichen wird dann ist das ein
desaster mit ansage und das ist
inakzeptabel
während auch die luftfahrtbranche wird
der crooner krise mit milliarden
beträgen massiv mit steuergeldern
gestützt wurden hatten viele flughafen
dienstleister und airlines nichts
besseres zu tun als tausende
beschäftigte zu entlassen oder sie mit
abfindungen sich vom hals zu schaffen
und bei dem die bleiben durfte reicht
das kurzarbeitergeld vielfach einfach
nicht um über die runden zu kommen ist
auch kein wunder dass sich viele von
ihnen dann in dieser krise nach einem
neuen job umgeschaut haben doch das
haben wir als fraktion die linke hier
übrigens während der pandemie immer
wieder eingefordert dass nicht nur das
kurzarbeitergeld erhöht wird damit die
leute auch in den branchen gehalten
werden können für nach der panne sondern
auch das dafür gesorgt wird dass die
wirtschaftshilfen an eine
beschäftigungssicherung gekoppelt wird
die große koalition hat nichts getan das
ist ein versagen in amerika
die probleme an den deutschen flughäfen
liegen in der tat tiefer wir haben es
hier mit einem maroden system zu tun das
auch miserablen arbeitsbedingungen das
hat meine vorrednerin zu recht gesagt
beruht viele der jobs bei der
gepäckabfertigung oder auf dem flugfeld
sind echte knochenjobs kann ich jedem
nur empfehlen sich mal mit den
kolleginnen kollegen dort zu unterhalten
und trotzdem wird viel fahrt dort nur
knapp über mindestlohn bezahlen wo die
leute lange zeit in teilzeit modelle
gepresst weil es der flexibilität der
unternehmer geholfen hat um den auch
angebotsdruck an dieser stelle der
billig airlines standhalten zu können
und dann wundern sich wenn sich viel am
ende des tages nach anderen jobs
umschauen das absurd meine damen und
herren und das muss sich ändern
das alles auch keines wird vom himmel
gefallen sondern es ist politisch
gewollt und hier sind in der tat die
fußstapfen der cdu das muss man sagen
sehr sehr sehr tiefen die
liberalisierung im flugverkehr und an
den flughäfen mitte der 90er jahre hat
dazu geführt dass aufgaben privatisiert
und zersplittert wurden künstlicher
wettbewerb geschaffen wurde das ergebnis
billig ausschreibungen
personaleinsparungen ein massives
lohndumping
natürlich hat die zersplitterung der
verschiedenen dienstleistungen zu
zahlreichen steuerungsprobleme an den
flughäfen geführt die auch teil des
heutigen chaos ich sagen der über diese
fatale politischen versäumnisse und
weichenstellungen nicht reden will der
sollte auch über das aktuelle chaos an
den deutschen flughäfen besser schweigen
meine damen und herren
jetzt soll es also die türkischen
kolleginnen und kollegen richten die
suppe auslöffeln die er hier das
versagen der flugunternehmen und auch
der dienstleister an den flughäfen und
zum teil auch der bundesregierung in den
letzten vier jahren uns eingebrockt hat
und es ist entscheidend in der tatort
das haben teile meiner vorredner und
vorhergesagt dass diese beschäftigten
die wenn sie dann überhaupt kommen da
gibt es noch ein großes fragezeichen
hier anständig behandelt wird anständig
bezahlt werden wir begrüßen es
ausdrücklich das bundesministerium für
arbeit soziales zusammen mit der
bundesagentur da versucht hat vorsorge
zu treffen aber entscheiden wird
natürlich sein dass diese
arbeitsbedingungen der praxis auch
tatsächlich so umgesetzt werden dass es
nicht de facto doch zum unterlaufen von
tarifverträgen von mindestlöhnen und
auch von mindestarbeitsbedingungen kommt
da muss jetzt genau hingeguckt werden
beamte
und eine nachhaltige lösung des problems
sieht natürlich anders aus weil das
problem die ich schon gesagt habe tief
als deswegen würde ich mir von herzen
dass das was teile meiner vorredner und
vorredner gesagt dazu führt dass die
bundesregierung auch noch mal richtung
europäischer ebene eine initiative
startet damit die deregulierung die wir
an den flughäfen dank europäischer
rahmensetzungen haben endlich
zurückgenommen wird und wieder
anständige bedingungen auch an den
flughäfen hier auch geschaffen werden
können
sorgen sie das das am arbeitsmarkt
wieder für ordnung geschaffen damit ihr
es auch sich wieder lohnt hart zu
arbeiten und man nicht das gefühl hat
man ist nicht gewollt mit prekärer
beschäftigung teilzeit erzwungen mit
leiharbeit und so weiter sorgen so für
dann haben wir auch ein geringeres
problem was die frage der arbeitskräfte
in prekären jobs am city zum schluss ich
glaube zum schluss frau präsidentin ich
hoffe sehr dass die bundesregierung aus
der aktuellen krise land und dafür sorgt
dass wir künftig nicht mehr ein solches
chaos an den flughäfen haben dass
künftig damit auch kein solcher
arbeitskräfte machen wir ist weil der
anschläge arbeitsgrundlage sagt herr mal
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
yvonne mag was stoppt die ausführung von
pascal maier der aber sowieso am ende
seines meines klubs angekommen ist das
ganze hat übrigens doch einem
hintergrund denn die debatten dauer
heute wenn ihr alles so zugeht wie es im
moment geplant ist wird wahrscheinlich
frühestens um 2 uhr 30 ändern da wird
sicher nicht wenden da wird sicherlich
die eine oder andere rede noch zu
protokoll gegeben werden aber es wird
sich in den sehr sehr späten abend
hinein ziehen beziehungsweise in den
recht frühen morgen und da muss man mal
gucken wir das hier gegen abgeordneten
diszipliniert bleiben jürgen lehnen das
zum beispiel aus der fdp-fraktion und
wir sind weiter in der debatte um das
chaos an den flughäfen
für dieses dilemma entschuldigen aber
ich kann ihnen sagen wir sehen diese
bilder durchaus und wir wollen als
politik auch versuchen möglichst abhilfe
zu schaffen meine damen und herren wir
haben hier eine situation die airlines
und die flughäfen brauchen vor allen
dingen eins ist personal und da muss ich
dann schon sagen da wundert mich die der
redebeitrag von den unionskollegen doch
dann schon sehr oder eher märz jetzt
müssen wir nicht auf die 16 jahre
reflektieren setzt in diesem selbst in
diesem redebeitrag scheuen sie das wie
der teufel das weihwasser zu sagen dass
deutschland ein
wanderung ins land ist wir sind ein
einwanderungsland unser ziel der
zehntplatzierte union dass wir ein
vernünftiges
einwanderungsgesetz bekommen und das
wird diese koalition ändern meine damen
und herren
meine damen und herren die unternehmen
stellen natürlich fest dass sie nicht
mehr der große attraktive arbeitgeber
sind wie sie es in der vergangenheit
waren und stoßen damit auch noch auf
einen arbeitsmarkt der nahezu
vollbeschäftigung hat das ist natürlich
etwas was die sache sehr erschwert zur
zeit und es wäre deutlich besser gewesen
wir hätten jetzt was die zuwanderung
anbelangt schon eine deutliche
arbeitserleichterung
zum arbeitsmarkt etwas anderes ist da
ist jetzt überhaupt noch nicht die rede
davon gewesen das ist was können wir
denn eigentlich an den flughäfen machen
ich fand das dann auch schon sehr
erstaunlich in dem antrag der union zu
lesen
dass die union sagt der
bundesverkehrsminister wäre ja nicht für
die personalpolitik bei den
fluggesellschaften zuständig und den
flughäfen das würde sie doch schon sehr
verwundert meine damen und herren so was
hätte ich ja eher von den linken das ist
eine position da hätte ich mich mit
kollegin janine wissler wunderbar im
hessischen landtag darüber streiten
können aber dass so eine these aus den
reihen der union kommt wo ich schon
sagen starker tobak aber das lassen wir
dann einfach mal so stehen ich glaube
das spricht für sich selbst die damen
meine damen und herren die flughäfen
brauchen mehr beinfreiheit wir haben
hier auch eine zuständigkeit in den
ländern und meine damen und herren von
der union in nicht wenigen ländern
regieren sie ja mit da könnten sie also
ihren eigenen beitrag dazu leisten an
dem ganzen dilemma und an der misere
abhilfe zu schaffen wir können
sicherlich nicht den menschen
versprechen dass in diesem sommer alles
wieder gut sein wird das wird nicht so
sein aber die politik die
bundesregierung steht an der seite der
luftverkehrswirtschaft und wird hier
abhilfe schaffen so weit es geht soweit
das möglich ist und dann gilt es aus dem
ganzen dilemma auch etwas zu lernen und
für die zukunft auch konsequenzen zu
ziehen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit verspricht jürgen lenders
aus der fdp fraktion in der debatte über
das chaos und das fehlende personal an
deutschlands flughäfen und in dieser
debatte jetzt julia klöckner
wirtschaftspolitische sprecherin der
unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen halten wir erstmal fest
deutschland ist das land der bildung der
forscher der entwickler der
qualitätsarbeit und für medien germany
sind wir in europa und in der ganzen
welt bekannt gefragt sind unsere
produkte unsere dienstleistung aber auch
unsere arbeits und fachkräfte unsere
unternehmen und beschäftigten die
arbeiten international allein
zehntausende deutsche handwerksbetriebe
arbeiten grenzüberschreitend und zuletzt
sind
180 tausend deutsche mit guter
ausbildung
abgewandert ins ausland deutschland und
china
deutschland ist er gut jetzt kommt
wieder dank cdu ich freue mich dass die
fdp das gerade sagt die fdp ist jetzt
gerade die partei die dafür sorgt dass
die die arbeiten könnten und
sanktioniert werden wenn sie keine
arbeit aufnehmen und andere das bezahlen
jetzt dafür sorgt dass diese sanktionen
abgeschafft wird eine sage ich danke fdp
dann ist das eine und tunis 17 erlauben
sie eine zwischenfrage aus den reihen
der fdp sehr gerne
[Applaus]
ja frau klöckner was wir erleben an den
flughäfen und den arbeitskräftemangel
insgesamt in deutschland
das kommt ja nicht über nacht sie haben
vielleicht schon mal das wort
demographie entwicklung gehört aber
umgesetzt in den 16 jahren haben sie
nicht sie sind mit einem blindflug gar
eingeflogen sie haben keine maßnahmen
getroffen und das einwanderungsgesetz
was wir jetzt bringen ist die erste
wirksame maßnahmen alle anderen
maßnahmen die auch vorher getroffen
worden sind waren nicht so wirksam 10
hätten durch schlagen können haben sie
schon mal was von demographie gehört
habe denke ich sehr für diesen zwischen
impuls bei diesem zwischen dem puls will
ich ganz kurz eine sage eben hat die
haben einer der vorredner davon
gesprochen dass auch die länder
verantwortlich sind ich erinnere gerade
daran dass in rheinland pfalz die fdp
mitregiert und der flughafen dort genau
das gegenteil von dem ist was wir uns
gewünscht hätten an der entwicklung was
ob sie das schon mal gehört haben aber
was wir mitbekommen haben ist was
anderes sehen wer war nun mal auch als
wenn die fdp ne frage stellt gehe ich
davon aus dass die fdp eine antwort
haben will aber wenn das dann noch mal
kommentiert wird von der fdp zeigt sich
dass sie mit antworten die ihnen wehtun
nicht umgehen können also sie müssen
sich schon überlegen ob sie fragen
stellen und mit dem hunger einfach
umgehen können oder lassen sie es mit
der frage zweiter punkt ich möchte auf
ihre frage auch noch eine antworten
demographie ja
stichwort demographie ob wir das zur
kenntnis nehmen es geht ja nicht nur um
die flughäfen wie sie auch im antrag
gesehen haben es geht auch um bahn
fahrten und da frag ich umgekehrt ob sie
schon mal in jüngster zeit regionalbahn
gefahren sind die fdp hat mit zugestimmt
dass ein euro ticket quasi über nacht
eingeführt worden sind hat mich stadt
gesorgt dass die kapazitäten dass das
personal da ist um das das gegenteil von
guter planung das frust und das führt
dazu dass die dino arbeiten dort sich
krank melden weil sie nicht mehr können
dank der fdp
deshalb liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
deutschland ist noch nach china und den
usa eines der größten exportländer der
welt und wir sehen das krisenbedingt die
ausfuhren zurückgegangen sind und dass
gäste mal seit zehn jahren und warum
sage ich das weil made in germany kein
selbstläufer ist weil made in germany
gerade gefährdet ist wir leben von der
substanz und eine bundesregierung die
das nicht sieht die nicht gegensteuert
eine solche bundesregierung gefährdet
unser aller wohlstand hier in
deutschland
und eine bundesregierung wie stattdessen
noch auflagen und
dokumentationspflichten für unternehmen
in diesen seiten vorsieht eine
bundesregierung die die anreize zur
arbeitsaufnahme sogar noch streicht eine
solche bundesregierung hat den ernst der
aktuellen lage noch nicht erkannt
und in deutschland sind aktuell
1,74 millionen offene stellen tendenz
steigend aber die zentren eigentümer die
tendenz der arbeitslosen in deutschland
ist auch steigen man muss das
zusammenbringen und für die hälfte der
offenen stellen in digital berufen
finden sich deutschlandweit keine
personal wir müssen uns immer wieder
klar machen noch einmal erfolgt ist kein
selbstläufer das muss hart erarbeitet
werden und gerade deshalb ist jetzt eine
richtige wirtschaftspolitik gefragt und
erreichen jetzt auch foto runden im
kanzleramt ohne ergebnisse und
erklärvideos aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium die reichen bei
weitem nicht aus wir brauchen jetzt
klare bessere rahmenbedingungen für
wettbewerbsfähiges wirtschaften in
krisenzeiten und was macht die
bundesregierung
die hat irgendwie die ruhe weg sie
kündigt an dass sie eine fachkräfte
strategie ende diesen jahres vorlegen
will das sind glauben sie dass die
bilder am flughafen und an den bahnhöfen
irgendwie im herbst alle herum sind nur
weil die leute nicht mehr im urlaub
fahren also erst ende 22 eine fachkräfte
strategie vorzulegen das ist zu spät das
ist keine entscheidung das ist auch
keine umsetzung und deshalb sagen wir
sehr klar weil es keine vorübergehende
erscheinung ist muss jetzt klar
gehandelt werden im übrigen auch für die
umsetzung der ökologischen und
ökonomischen
transformation so wie es auch das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium denn was
brauchen wir ganz klar die
arbeitsagenturen und jobcenter müssen
stärker helfen personal zu finden und
gerade das prinzip fördern und fordern
noch einmal dass es jetzt instinktlos
das abzuschaffen zweiter punkt 6
millionen menschen die von transfers
leben während grundsätzlich arbeitsfähig
lassen uns doch mal gedanken machen wie
wir hier in deutschland lebende
überhaupt in arbeit bekommen das
schließt nicht aus dass wir auch besser
dafür sorgen dass auf grundlage des
guten fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetzes
die praxis auch besser funktioniert aber
da geht es um in der praxis dass die
visa verfahren zum beispiel auch
schneller laufen oder azubi ticket
einzeln für den öpnv für auszubildende
die berufs und ausrüstungs muss
individueller werden kinderbetreuung
besser werden und bei der einwanderung
noch einmal sage ich auch sehr klar wir
müssen schauen dass das was als gesetzte
vorgelegt worden ist in der umsetzung
besser wird und deshalb fordern wir die
bundesregierung auch nicht viel reden
nicht viel beschreiben sondern
entscheiden und auch machen das ist
jetzt gefragt
und für die spd-fraktion erteile ich das
wort russia nasa
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren werte
kolleginnen und kollegen nach den
monaten und jahren da einschränkungen
und der entbehrung freuen wir uns alle
wieder auf den sommer und damit auf die
urlaubszeit was natürlich ärgerlich ist
wenn der urlaub noch am flughafen ende
wenn flüge gestrichen werden der
check-in nicht klappt oder die
bodenabfertigung einfach so lange dauert
das man den flug schlichtweg verpasst so
wie ja eigentlich niemand von uns in den
urlaub starten dass es aber gerade
realität für viele menschen in diesem
land und einmal mehr erleben wir wie
wichtig ausreichend und gut bezahltes
personal es egal in welcher branche
mit beginn der korona pandemie hat
besonders das bundesarbeitsministerium
unter leitung von hubertus heil schnell
gehandelt und eine brücke gebaut die
dabei geholfen hat arbeitsplätze zu
sichern das kurzarbeitergeld ja und
viele unternehmen haben sich dieses
instruments angenommen konnten so ihre
mitarbeiter inhalten aber trotz dieser
möglichkeit des kurzarbeitergeldes kam
es zur freistellung oder entlassungen
und das merken wir jetzt besonders an
unseren flughäfen und viele haben
mittlerweile eben auch eine neue
perspektive in anderen branchen gefunden
und lassen sie uns bitte eines
festhalten privatwirtschaftliche
unternehmen sind selbst für ihre
personalpolitik und deren folgen
verantwortlich aber unabhängig davon hat
die bundesregierung denn auf einen plan
vorgelegt und sorgt für schnelle hilfe
bundesverkehrsminister volker wissing
bundesinnenminister in nancy faeser und
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil
haben sich bei einem gemeinsamen treffen
mit den zuständigen verantwortlichen des
flugbetriebs beraten und am 29 juni eine
lösung vorgestellt die schnell abhilfe
schaffen soll vorgeschlagen wird ein
zeitlich befristeter und pragmatischer
weg der kurzfristig für schnelle hilfe
sorgen wird für drei monate sollen
kolleginnen eines türkischen
bodenabfertigung unternehmens unsere
leute hier unterstützen natürlich achten
wir dabei darauf dass sie ordentlich
zwar nach tarif entlohnt und vernünftig
untergebracht werden und es ist
eigentlich traurig dass wir auf dieses
instrument zurückgreifen müssen ich
wiederhole mich gern die unternehmen
sind selbst verantwortlich für ihre
personalpolitik deshalb werden wir die
unternehmen auch nicht aus der
verantwortung entlassen
mittel und langfristig selbst für eine
ordentliche personalpolitik zu sorgen ja
und an dieser stelle könnte ich meine
rede eigentlich beenden aber wir
behandeln hier einen antrag der union
den es meiner meinung nach eigentlich
gar nicht mehr gebraucht hätte
schauen wir uns den antrag mal genauer
an dann muss man sich doch sehr wundern
ich gleich mal zwei der vier forderungen
aus dem ersten teil auf darin wird unter
anderem gefordert eine flugreise gipfel
unter beteiligung der zuständigen
bundesminister einzuberufen der dann
klären soll in welchem umfang personal
gebraucht wird ja ist erledigt dafür
jetzt nicht meinen gipfel gebraucht oder
auch schön mit denen für die
organisation des flugbetriebs
verantwortlichen eine optimale
abstimmung vorzunehmen auch das erledigt
ich weiß nicht wo sie letzte woche waren
bei der pressekonferenz die wurden nun
weiterhin fordern sie die regierung auf
allgemein geeignete maßnahmen zur
linderung des arbeits- und
fachkräftemangels zu ergreifen so weit
so gut aber kein wort dazu wie sie sich
fachkräftegewinnung aus dem ausland
vorstellen das müssten sie
wahrscheinlich auch mal ihre position
überdenken was einwanderung generell
gilt ich bin froh ja und dieses
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetz hat ja
das funktioniert genau deshalb nicht
weil es unter ihrer blockade nicht
funktioniert hat gebrauchen 400.000
leute pro jahr haben sie selbst
mittlerweile festgestellt 30 die conti
voran liegen doch
kommen wir zurück zum antrag sie fordern
dass linderung geschaffen werden soll
indem zum beispiel die jobcenter und
arbeitsagenturen angehalten werden
sollen und an ihm zügig bei der
einstellung von arbeitskräften zu
unterstützen oder die berufliche aus und
weiterbildung zu stärken oder die
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf zu
verbessern finde ich sehr interessant
denn was ich daran erstaunlich finde ist
dass die union offenbar auch ein
soziales herz entdeckt habt wo warnen
dass die sich die letzten 16 jahre wo
waren diese vorschläge in den letzten 16
jahren die trauben nicht von ihm die kam
vor allem vom bundesarbeitsminister und
von der spd wie lange standen union mit
beiden füßen auf der bremse ist es um
die einführung des mindestlohns ging um
nur ein beispiel zu nennen der stand in
letztens noch hier und hat lautstark
dass durch sanktionieren von menschen im
sgb 2 gefordert während wir bereits
daran arbeiten ordentliche lösungen zu
finden von dieser sinnlosen praxis
wegzukommen und menschen attraktive
angebote zu machen endlich wieder eine
arbeit aufzunehmen die ser mussten wir
ihnen jeden noch so kleinen sozialen
schritt ab kämpfen und jetzt stellen wir
sicher hinunter gerieren sich als die
die veränderung herbei bringen ich bitte
sie jetzt
ihr kanzlerkandidat auch laschet hat im
wahlkampf mal gesagt spüren wenn ich
alle den winter veränderung der uns ins
gesicht nun ja es scheint so als sei die
union das fähnchen im wind der
veränderung da von dieser regierung
ausgeht nur finde ich daran absurd dass
sie offenbar alle zeit darin investieren
ihr von möglichst falsch in den wind zu
stellen daher märz wie wäre es wenn sie
ihre fraktion konstruktive
oppositionsarbeit nahe leben würden
anstatt unsere zeit mit anträgen in
anspruch zu nehmen deren inhalt bereits
in umsetzung oder beschlossen dass
vielleicht gucken wissen immer in den
koalitionsvertrag bevor die anträge
schreiben vielleicht kommt die dann oft
auf eigene ideen also ich glaube es ist
sehr deutlich geworden ich sag's aber
gern noch mal wir nehmen diesen antrag
ab
chaos an den flughäfen
arbeitskräfte gewinnung darüber
diskutiert der bundeswehr das war für
die spd und die nächste rednerin kommt
von der hfg garrett i
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren die situation
an deutschen flughäfen ist chaotisch
1000 flüge müssen gecancelt werden weil
flug und flughafengesellschaften in der
korona krise zu viel personal abgebaut
haben und jetzt offensichtlich ganz
verwenden da soll nun die
bundesregierung einspringen das
überrascht ein bisschen oder während die
union noch erst ein gipfelgespräch
vorschlagen möchte oder vorschalten
möchte prescht die bundesregierung mit
der idee vor
1500 neue arbeitskräfte aus der türkei
einzufliegen klappt zwar erst nach den
sommerferien aber es gibt ja auch wieder
herbstferien und dann kommen auch noch
die weihnachtsferien für läuft hätte
gibt es ja dann wie er von afg halten
keinen dieser vorschläge für zielführend
die frage die sich doch aufdrängt ist
doch eher weshalb ist unter den über
zwei millionen arbeitslosen keine 1500
menschen gibt die diese arbeiten
ausführen können
[Applaus]
wo sind denn die menschen aus der
vorführung der zeit geblieben haben sie
sich aus dem berufsleben verabschiedet
wohl kaum sie haben befriedigende hre
und wahrscheinlich auch besser bezahlte
jobs gefunden die arbeit an den
flughafen ist schwer sie ist prekär es
ist ein sind meistens rainer anlagen
jobs mit wochenenddiensten
schichtdiensten urlaubs verboten und so
weiter und sie sind nicht gut bezahlt
der unterschied zur hartz 4 ist nicht
allzu groß und jetzt will sie niemand
machen das ist insofern pikant als
praktisch alle großen deutschen
flughäfen in öffentlicher hand sind also
der flughafen der bundeshauptstadt
berlin ist zu 100 prozent in
staatsbesitz genauso in der flughafen in
münchen in köln bonn sind es 90 prozent
entsprechend gut sind die gehälter der
flughafenchef sie liegen zwischen 400
und 500 1000 euro und damit weit über
der minister liege man sollte annehmen
dass diese fürstlich bezahlten manager
es schaffen vernünftige
arbeitsverhältnisse herzustellen und man
sollte noch mehr annehmen dass der staat
der den aufsichtsräten sitzt genau dafür
sorgt insbesondere dann wenn sich die
bundesregierung als links bezeichnet und
vielleicht ist das ja auch der grund
dass die ampel so ganz schnell und in
panik diese peinlichkeit beseitigen will
statt auf bessere arbeitsverhältnissen
drängen versucht sie einen billiglöhner
import also eine neue gastarbeiter an
werbung mit all den problemen die sich
daraus ergeben angefangen von der
sprache von der erschwerten
sicherheitsüberprüfung und von der
erschwerten wohnungs unterbringung es
ist zudem keine dauerhafte lösung denn
sie ist nur für begrenzte zeit für 90
tage plus geplant
das heißt zu den nächsten osterferien
dürfen wir mit dem nächsten flughafen
chaos rechnen
oder steckt vielleicht einen geheimplan
darunter dass die ampel witz masse
insbesondere der klima minister habe
geplant die flugpreise wieder so
heraufzusetzen dass er den
flugplan herunterfahren kann und sich
überhaupt nur noch seine eigenen wähler
das fliegen leisten können in
deutschland
wenn das nicht der fall ist sollten sich
besseren arbeitsbedingungen zu wenden
kommen sie zum schluss ja
[Applaus]
und für bündnis 90 die grünen hat das
wort susanne menge
ja und susanne menge ist die obfrau im
verkehrsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
zuhörerinnen und zuhörer es ist uns
allen inzwischen glaube ich klar
geworden dass die union mit diesem
antrag die aufmerksamkeits welle mit
diesem sommer reisechaos 2022 reitet
denn dankeschön liebe kollegin nasa der
antrag gibt ansonsten nicht viel her in
dem teil in dem aktuellen flughafen
chaos dem sie sich dem aktuellen
flughafen chaos widmen fordern sie vor
allen dingen die die bundesregierung
bereits in angriff genommen und
gegenüber der presse fand ich zumindest
ausreichend kommuniziert hat eine
ressortübergreifende arbeitsgruppe der
bundesregierung arbeitet an maßnahmen
zur verbesserung es ist gerade
ausreichend vorgestellt worden sie
fordern dass hilfe im rahmen der zur
verfügung stehenden haushaltsmittel
geleistet wird wenn die bundesregierung
jetzt organisatorische hilfestellung für
die flughäfen leistet dann ist das in
ordnung es ist gut die reisenden nicht
im regen stehen zu lassen angesichts
knapper kassen darf die hilfe aber nicht
mit weiteren belastungen für den
angespannten bundeshaushalt verbunden
sein fluggesellschaften flughäfen und
reiseveranstalter in den wurden in der
korona krise ich erinnere mit
milliardenschweren hilfsprogrammen
unterstützt auch darf die hilfsaktion
nicht zu viele kräfte binden denn beim
thema reisesommer 22 geht es um ein
vergleichsweise überschaubares problem
besonders im luftverkehr haben wir
nämlich ein sehr viel weitreichenderes
problem zu lösen für einen weniger
klimaschädlichen luftverkehr müssen wir
alle kräfte bündeln die
luftverkehrsbranche hat das flughafen
chaos zu nicht unerheblichen teilen
übrigens auch selbst zu verantworten das
ausgeweitete kurzarbeitergeld hätte es
ermöglicht mehr schwer zu ersetzen das
personal zu halten die krise darf nicht
dafür genutzt werden um nicht nur
bestehende sondern auch künftige
personalkosten womöglich zu drücken wir
stellen außerdem fest dass viele
entlassene mitarbeiter in den jetzt
nicht an ihren arbeitsplatz am flughafen
zurückkehren wollen das spricht für sich
die billig tickets strategie und das
damit verbundene anheizen des
verkehrswachstums rächen sich eben auch
an dieser stelle
bei aller problematik die an den
flughäfen zu beobachten ist gibt es aber
niemandem das recht gegen
flughafenpersonal
aggressiv und unangenehm vorzugehen das
polizeikräfte das flugpersonal die uns
schützen müssen ist ein beschämendes
beispiel auch für mangelnde umgang mit
dieser krise auf einen begleiteffekt
möchte ich an dieser stelle allerdings
mit nachdruck hinweisen sprinter-züge
entlang der innerdeutschen flug strecken
sind jetzt bis zu 40 prozent stärker
ausgebucht viele tickets werden dabei
von den airlines als ersatz für
ausgefallene flüge verkauft na also es
geht doch
der nächste redner herkommt aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion der zuständige
stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende für den bereich
verkehr ulrich lange
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ja das was wir derzeit an
unseren flughäfen sehen ist peinlich für
unser land und es schadet unserem land
in der reputation und es schadet dem
standort und dass die menschen an den
flughäfen liebe kollegin menge wütend
sind und die politik dann eine debatte
über das führt ist richtig das ist nicht
verwerflich sondern das ist die aufgabe
von uns als politikerinnen und
politikern uns damit auseinanderzusetzen
und was die leute ärger ist dann das
gefühl
tatenlos zuzuschauen die probleme lang
laufen zu lassen und zu ignorieren und
warum sage ich das ja wir haben
herausfordernde zeiten in der verkehrs
wirtschaft und reisebranche ja wir
hatten corona und wir haben den
angriffskrieg russlands das ist aber nur
ein teil der begründung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen aus
verkehrspolitischer sicht denn wir haben
durchgehend
konjunkturelle lage genau
wir haben durchgängig strukturelle
probleme im luftverkehr
herr minister wissing und die sind auch
bekannt denn frau kollegin asa
2018 hat es unter dem damaligen
verkehrsminister mit ihrer beteiligung
in der regierung möchte ich nur sagen
haben leider nicht 16 jahre allein
regiert einen luftverkehrs apple gegeben
und da wurden
arbeitsaufträge in der branche und in
den einzelnen häusern verteilt und herr
minister klemmen sie diese oder kennen
sie diese nicht denn dann hätte man
reagieren können und müssen nach corona
wenn der luftverkehr wieder startet
man hat zielsicher und schnell in der
pandemie gehandelt aber man wusste was
man tut um das
bundesverkehrsministerium weiß welche
hausaufgaben und deswegen braucht es
einen gipfel noch zu erledigen sind
außer scheinbar ihnen herr blindflug
minister um das wort des fdp kollegen
über den blindflug hier mal aufzugreifen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die die
personaldecke zugegebenermaßen dünn das
haben das haben airlines und die
flughäfen selbst mit zu verantworten sie
müssen sich natürlich fragen lassen was
aus den übrigen unterstützungs hilfen
geworden ist denn sie waren übrig das
haben wir hier auch liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der spd damals gemeinsam so
geregelt es gibt aber auch unterschiede
bei den flughäfen in diesem land auch
das erlaube ich mir
anzumerken der kollege lenders hat
vorhin gesagt die union regiert in den
ländern mit ja in berlin regiert die
union
nicht wir kennen alle br und seine
probleme die csu regiert in münchen und
der münchner flughafen funktioniert
immer noch ausgesprochen gut sieben
kolleginnen und kollegen denn trotz
allem anspruch um haben wir dort gerade
funktionierenden und relativ geordneten
flugverkehr ich kann nur auch wenn sie
es nicht hören können ihnen mal wieder
das bayerische modell an dieser stelle
empfehlen
kontinuität und stabilität in der
zusammenarbeit mit den
sicherheitsdienstleistern faire und
angemessene bezahlung der beschäftigten
einsatz der landespolizei neben der
bundespolizei und eine
verkehrsinfrastruktur die zu den
flughäfen passt und liebe kollegen menge
ich fahre viel icc reparatur flug
gecancelt das war mein montag also das
einfache ausweichen funktioniert bei
diesem chaos
ministerium derzeit im verkehr nicht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben kein erkenntnisproblem
herr minister wissen sie haben ein
umsatz problem nehmen sie das papier von
2018 dass wir zusammen mit den kollegen
der spd und der branche erarbeitet haben
luftverkehr personal flugsicherung
flughäfen bundespolizei alles
aufgeschrieben alles festgehalten sie
sind dran es zu regeln sie haben die
regierungsverantwortung die menschen
wollen fliegen die menschen wollen
reisen sie haben das recht dazu
dankeschön
[Applaus]
und ich hatte das wort der kollegen
kollegin doktor jurisch fdp fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren also der
antrag der union ist ja wohl ein
treppenwitz die situation die wir jetzt
haben das ist ihre situation verehrte
union und die russen muss man erst mal
haben so ein antrag vorzulegen
es ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht allen
bewusst unsere demografische entwicklung
ist eine schleichende katastrophe mit
ansage
unsere demografische entwicklung hat
gravierende folgen nicht auf unseren
arbeitsmarkt und insgesamt auf unserem
gesellschaftlichen wohlstand ohne
maßnahmen also wenn alles so weiterläuft
wie jetzt wird das
erwerbspersonenpotenzial
gemäß ihrer b in deutschland bis 2035
von 47 auf 40 millionen menschen sinken
wir können mit den maßnahmen die ihr
antrag enthält also mehr frauen
erwerbsbeteiligung der weiterbildung
bessere berufsorientierung usw diesen
effekt etwas abmildern aber selbst bei
deutlich erhöhten erwerbsquoten wird die
zahl der arbeitskräfte in deutschland
aufgrund der demografie weiter drastisch
zurückgehen schauen wir ganz konkret
auch mal in den arbeitsmarkt seit 20 12
hat sich die zahl der arbeitslosen pro
offener stelle rechnerisch von und fünf
personen auf etwas über eine person
konstant reduziert wenn das so
weitergeht werden wir bereits im
nächsten jahr mehr offene stellen als
arbeitslose haben es ist völlig klar
ohne eine deutlich gesteigerte gezielte
einwanderung in den arbeitsmarkt geht es
nicht wir bremsen uns sonst
volkswirtschaftlich aus wir können uns
die jährlich in deutschland fehlenden
zusätzlichen 400.000 menschen netto ja
nicht backen es ist also die lösung
nutzen wir doch jetzt endlich ein und
zwar dank der union noch ungehobenen
schatz nämlich den schatz der erkenntnis
dass wir uns war schon längst ein
einwanderungsland sind machen wir uns
frei von ideologischen ballast von dem
auch der antrag der union zeug nämlich
indem er das thema migration konsequent
ignoriert
die fortschritts koalition hat
vereinbart das einwanderungsrecht um ein
punktesystem zu ergänzen wir nennen das
chancen karte die chancen karte
ermöglicht menschen die einreise zur
stellensuche in mangelberufen die
chancen karte legt die entscheidung über
die eignung potenzieller mitarbeiter vor
allem in die hände künftiger arbeitgeber
die chancen karte wird strikt bedarf
bezogen ausgestaltet
arbeitsmarktexperten dann das englisch
ich beobachten die chancen karte ist
integrations orientiert und wird aspekte
die sprache deutsch und englisch sowie
praktische berufserfahrung und
beruflicher kompetenzen in den
mittelpunkt rücken mit der chancen karte
werden wir im internationalen wettbewerb
und in dem stehen wir wo motivierte und
talentierte arbeitskräfte wieder
attraktiver vollziehen wir endlich auch
migrations rechtlich den schritt zum
einwanderungsland dass wir schon längst
sind und nutzen wir diese chance für
unser land vielen dank
und ich erteile das wort für die
spd-fraktion der kollegin anja troska
waffen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in den
bundesländern beginnen nun nach und nach
die sommerferien und nach zwei jahren
pandemie haben alle wieder lust zu
reisen und auch zu fliegen das merkt man
natürlich überall doch während es so war
in der vergangenheit dass der nano
urlaub grund zur vorfreude war gucken
jetzt natürlich viele sehr sorgenvoll
auf ihre reise weil aufgrund der
zahlreichen flugausfälle eben manchmal
unklar ist ob und wann das gewünschte
ziel erreicht werden kann es ist klar
dass zunächst die betroffenen
unternehmen gefragt sind ich appelliere
daher ganz dringend an die luftverkehrs
wirtschaft einen möglichst stabilen
betrieb sicherzustellen
sie sind gefragt das kernversprechen
ihrer branche nämlich das von einer
pünktlichen und zuverlässigen
beförderung auch im sommer 2022 ein zu
lösen
außerdem ist klar dass ein streit
darüber wer die verantwortung trägt
nicht zielführend ist das löst weder das
kernproblem noch wird den gestrandeten
passagieren geholfen es ist angesichts
dessen äußerst bedauerlich dass sie
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der union
die immerhin von 2009 bis 2021 das
verkehrsministerium führten nun nichts
anzubieten haben außer fakten freien
schuldzuweisungen an die neue
bundesregierung
wir arbeiten lieber an der sache
einerseits wollen wir kurzfristig die
einschränkungen für die passagiere
minimieren andererseits wollen wir dass
der luftverkehr
mittelfristig zu einem stabilen betrieb
zurückkehrt das drängendste problem ist
der personalmangel insbesondere bei den
bodenverkehrsdiensten die
bundesregierung hat beim luft hat gipfel
handlungswillen und handlungsfähigkeit
gezeigt die gewinnung von 2000
zusätzlichen arbeitnehmenden für den für
die bodenverkehrsdienste ist ein
wichtiges signal durch beschleunigte
zuverlässigkeitsprüfung wir zeitnah
entlastung sichergestellt an dieser
stelle auch ein großes dankeschön an
unsere ministerinnen und minister peter
hain und bissing für diesen pro aktiven
einsatz denn darauf hat der kollege
lange gerade hingewiesen der damalige
verkehrsminister scheuer der union hat
im krisen zum krisengipfel im jahr 2018
zwar eingeladen aber erst nach dem ende
des chaotischen flug sommers nämlich
erst im oktober
natürlich sind die arbeitskräfte aus dem
ausland kein allheilmittel dass die
unternehmen durch entzerrung der
abfertigung und flugpläne ihre
kapazitäten ausschöpfen und
vermeintliche stornierungen müssen mit
minimalen unannehmlichkeiten für die
passagiere verbunden sein und natürlich
auch so früh wie möglich mitgeteilt
werden der rückblick auf die probleme
des jahres 2018 beweist dass die
ursachen der flugausfälle tiefgreifender
sind und grundsätzliche antworten
bedürfen die in den vielen berufsfeldern
der luftfahrt schwierigen
arbeitsbedingungen
teilweise gepaart mit schlechter
bezahlung sorgen seit langem für wenig
nachwuchs die unternehmen haben parallel
ihre personaldecke im zuge weiterer
kürzungen bereits vor der pandemie auf
ein gefährliches niedriges niveau
gesenkt
durch die berufliche unsicherheit und
massive kurzarbeit häufig eben auch ohne
aufstockung in den hier an der pandemie
haben viele arbeit nehmen die branche
verlassen und sie werden nur
zurückkehren wenn sich
arbeitsbedingungen und bezahlung
verbessern für uns gilt daher nur mit
mehr personal gibt es eine rückkehr zum
residenten flugbetrieb
wir setzen uns zusätzlich für eine
bessere organisation des luftverkehrs
ein die im koalitionsvertrag
festgehaltene umsetzung von single
european sky werden wir vorantreiben
die möglichkeiten der digitalisierung
werden und müssen wir nutzen um das
flughafenpersonal bei seiner arbeit zu
entlasten etwa bei der durchführung der
luftsicherheitskontrolle
und das stichwort
luftsicherheitskontrollen das thema ist
ein dauerbrenner
die kontrollen funktionieren je nach
organisation am jeweiligen flughafen
unterschiedlich gut und ich stimme dem
kollegen lange zu ein blick nach münchen
lohnt sich dort wird die hoheitliche
aufgabe nicht von einem privaten
dienstleister sondern von einer
landeseigenen gesellschaft durchgeführt
und das sehr gut die spd hat die großen
potenziale einer reorganisation der
luftsicherheitskontrollen etwa nach
diesem münchner modell bereits in der
letzten wahlperiode
herausgestellt eine grundsätzliche
verbesserung der situation von personal
und passagieren ist möglich doch innen
und verkehrsministerium blockierten
sämtliche bemühungen dieser
neuausrichtung dass zwei csu geführte
häuser nicht über ein erfolgreiches
bayerische bayerisches konzept reden
wollten ist bemerkenswert
uns ist sehr wohl bewusst
dass mit der debatte der reorganisation
erst ein langer politischer prozess
beginnt aber die spd fraktion geht auch
hier gerne voran und ist handlungswillig
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
redebeiträge verdeutlichen wie komplex
die thematik der flugausfälle ist ich
führe intensive gespräche mit
unternehmen gewerkschaften und behörden
und uns alle eint eine überzeugung es
wird nicht die einen so geben die
luftfahrt branche ist gefordert ihre
personal situation zu verbessern die
bundesregierung kümmert sich um die
rahmenbedingungen so wird der weg aus
der aktuellen krise gelingen aber das
gehört auch zur wahrheit dazu
leider nicht sofort denn die probleme
sind so groß dass sie sich nicht zum
ende des sommerflugplans in luft
auflösen werden vielen dank
der deutsche bundestag debattiert im
moment über einen antrag der cdu csu
fraktion chaos an den flughäfen
beseitigen sofortprogramm zur arbeits
und fachkräftegewinnung
auflegen die cdu csu fordert darin mit
inländischen fachkräften soll das
problem gelöst werden die ampel
regierung will ja unter einem
ausländische facharbeiter hinzuziehen
jetzt hier die erste rede von miss bad
kann von den bündnisgrünen
gerade haben so viele menschen aus
unterschiedlichsten gründen starke
belastung corinna begleitet uns immer
noch im familienleben und im alltag wir
haben steigende preise und globale
unsicherheiten und all das sorgt dafür
dass sich so viele menschen zu recht
eine auszeit wünschen so haben wir die
urlaubszeit und das steckt das land
steckt im reisechaos und wenn wir
traditionell natürlich bei bus und bahn
mit klimaanlagen kämpfen scheitern will
jetzt mit flugplänen und den
katastrophalen viel planung der branche
wer aber seit jahren niedrigste löhne
und schlechte arbeitsbedingungen hat
darf sich dann noch nicht für den
eigenen scherbenhaufen stellen und nach
hilfe
es ist nicht die aufgabe des staates
vorhersehbare
privatwirtschaftliches versagen
auszubügeln wir machen es jetzt trotzdem
nicht für die branche sondern für die
reisenden
und liebe union die täglich grüßt das
murmeltier
auch in sachen arbeitsmarktpolitik in
deutschland wer 16 jahre dieses land
regiert hat
gerne auch von dieser stelle
gerne auch von dieser stelle wer 16
jahre dieses land regiert hat und ich
zitiere jetzt aus ihrem antrag in dem
antrag feststellt dass man allen ecken
und enden sparen arbeitskräfte fehlen
verweist lediglich auf das eigene nicht
zum und versagen
währenddessen arbeiten wir seit jahren
an einer nachhaltigen willkommenskultur
und fordern eine progressive
einwanderungspolitik an denn der
personalmangel das wissen wir auch so
gut wie allen berufsbranchen ist die
zentrale herausforderung für die zeit
und deshalb brauchen wir auch mehr als
punktuelle antworten sondern wir
brauchen eine langfristige
gesamtstrategie
wir wollen mehr zuwanderung in den
arbeitsmarkt wir müssen dafür die hürden
bürokratische art senken wir müssen
dieses verfahren digitalisieren und
beschleunigen wir müssen qualifikation
leichter anerkennen der arbeitsmarkt dem
wir in der flugbranche haben wenn wir da
die kraftanstrengung die es braucht in
kauf nehmen um dieses marktversagen
auszugleichen dann wird uns das viel
mühe kosten es wird uns viel mühe kosten
tausende arbeitskräfte anzuwerben und es
ist dann aber kein dank wenn dem herbst
sagen tschüss und zurück wenn diese
menschen sich dafür entscheiden doch
hier bleiben und hier arbeiten tun das
heißt in einer solchen situation
für menschen die uns jetzt hier zur
seite springen braucht es eine
bleibeperspektive wir müssen auch
ehrlich miteinander sein
wir müssen wir müssen auch ehrlich
miteinander sein auch nach dem sommer
werden die arbeitskräfte aus dem ausland
brauchen und wenn wir uns den
koalitionsvertrag anschauen dann könnt
ihr sicher sein die punkte die wir da
die wieder beschlossen haben sind erste
schritte um den arbeitskräfte markt
aufzuräumen an der stelle dass das muss
ich mir auch an der stelle nicht
verkneifen oder darf ich mir nicht
verkneifen mit oder ohne englisch als
zweite amtssprache vielen dank
so mies balkan bekommt hier aus den
fraktionen viel applaus das war ihre
erste rede hier im haus michael otto
wulff jetzt für die cdu/csu sie sitzt im
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales
[Applaus]
explizit mal aus von dem was ich jetzt
sage aber manchmal habe ich das gefühl
bei den debatten hier wenn wir jedes mal
fünf euro ins phrasenschwein schmeißen
würden für die 16 jahre dann hätten am
ende der legislatur den haushalt saniert
also vielleicht
und das wünschen wir uns von ihnen das
sage ich hier ganz explizit fangen sie
jetzt und heute einfach mal an
verantwortung zu übernehmen denn sie
sind jetzt die regierung in diesem land
sie stellen jetzt die regierung ja dann
gucken wir mal hin wie sie das machen
der flugbetrieb darüber reden wir heute
der flugbetrieb und das was wir erleben
das ist eine folge und das wissen sie
alle des lockdown denn im lok dann
wurden die fluggesellschaften auf null
runtergefahren das war wirklich eine
derart betroffenen branchen in diesem
lockdown und jetzt wird die branche
innerhalb weniger monaten läuft diese
branche wider wo jetzt hören sie mir
doch mal zu und das geht nicht so
einfach und reibungslos und es ist
sicher auch eine ausnahme lage aber
gerade weil es eine ausnahme lage ist da
erwarten wir jetzt in die minister nicht
mehr da aber die staatssekretäre richten
mir sicher gerne aus da warten wir von
den ministern in diesem land dass sie
sich an einen tisch setzen und zwar mit
arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmervertretern
und zwar rechtzeitig und dass sie sich
nicht hier hinstellen und sagen für
personalpolitik sind wir nicht
verantwortlich für diese lage können wir
nichts das wussten wir auch alles gar
nicht und das sollen doch bitte schön
die firma einmal selber reden wir haben
den rocksaum begleitet und wir sollten
sie auch danach weiterhin begleiten in
guter sozialpartnerschaftlicher
tradition aber in dieser regierung fehlt
anscheinend das korrektiv der union um
genau solche initiativen haben zu geben
und ich sage ich ihnen noch was das was
wir heute erleben das ist ein
vorgeschmack auf das was die menschen in
diesem land erleben wenn dieser
regierung beim thema fachkräftesicherung
nicht einfach mal drei gänge oder
vielleicht sogar vier zuschaltet ja die
zahlen die sind uns bekannt und auch die
herausforderungen des fachkräftemangels
dpa spricht von 400.000 zuwanderern die
wir jährlich brauchen 1,7 millionen
stellen sind in deutschland unbesetzt
und wir sind uns einig viel brauchen
zuwanderung und wir brauchen
qualifizierung und wir brauchen
weiterbildung aber dann kommen wir doch
mal hin was aktuell ist in der jetzigen
lage passiert und wie diese
bundesregierung reagiert denn
860.000 menschen sind aus der ukraine zu
uns gekommen in den letzten monaten
davon überwiegend 72 prozent frauen
viele mit guten qualifikationen auch in
den mangelberufen die wir dringend
brauchen wie schläge und wie erziehung
und natürlich steht schutz hier an
oberster stelle aber viele wollen ja
auch arbeiten und das wäre doch jetzt
die chance gewesen frau staatsministerin
dass sie endlich mal an die
anerkennungsverfahren rangehen und
endlich mal vereinfachung herbeiführen
aber nichts haben sie getan herr heil
hat mit mir diese frage im plenum hier
diskutiert und hat mir erklärt dass das
vielschichtig ist unkompliziert und
alles nicht geht ja sie sind in der
regierung wir erwarten lösungsvorschläge
von ihnen wie man endlich die
anerkennung verbessern kann
[Applaus]
ja genau
und meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
das hat der kanzler in der fragestunde
auch noch einmal bestätigt dass er der
kanzlerin da jetzt hören sie mir mal tue
und diskutieren bitte nicht nach unten
weiter
der kanzler hat gestern bestätigt dass
wir eines der liberalen 1 waren wir uns
rechte in dieser gesellschaft haben und
deshalb meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren das was ihr die die strukturen
der sozialen integration die müssen wir
aufbauen und vergessen verbessern und
langfristig eine willkommenskultur
machen was macht aber die
bundesregierung die bundesregierung sagt
das was da passiert ist nicht unser
problem aber jana gut nun werden wir
einfach noch mal kurzfristig fachkräfte
in unser land holen das kann nicht
zielführend sein das ist keine gute
strategie wir erwarten an dieser stelle
mehr von ihnen und nicht hektisch über
ein ecktisch eine schnelle eine schnelle
zuwanderung das ist nun wirklich keine
lösung wo das kind schon in den brunnen
gefallen ist kommen sie bitte zum
schluss vielleicht noch einsatz heute
gilt mehr denn je und wie früher auch
wir rufen arbeitskräfte und es kommen
menschen zu uns und um diese menschen
sollten wir uns kümmern und vor allen
dingen sollten wir auch dafür sorgen
dass diejenigen die heute in
arbeitslosigkeit sind 2,4 millionen
menschen auch in ihre strategie der
fachkräftesicherung und eingezogen
werden und in arbeit integriert werden
schnellstmöglich vielen dank
mareike lotte bull war das von der cdu
csu es ist gut dass der bundestag sich
mit diesen wichtigen themen beschäftigt
wie zum beispiel dem chaos an den
flughäfen die frage wie man das
abstellen kann alles sehr gut aber viel
zu spät heute wieder ein riesenchaos zum
beispiel in hamburg wo die ferien
angefangen haben 40.000 warten über
einen dreiviertel stunden warten allein
damit wir durch die sicherheitsschleusen
kommt das sind zustände die wünscht sich
niemand vor seinem urlaub pascal kober
jetzt für dich aber zunächst einmal
liebe frau lotte wulff es gab doch einen
runden tisch im verkehrsministerium man
allen beteiligten und verantwortlichen
zusammen das gespräch gesucht hat aber
was sie glaube ich nicht begriffen haben
ist folgendes auf der einen seite sind
werden der pandemie 12 bis 15 prozent
des luft- und bodenpersonal in den
flughäfen verloren gegangen im
flugbetrieb verloren kann aber wo sind
die denn die sind jetzt in anderen
branchen die arbeiten jetzt
beispielsweise bei sicherheitsdiensten
außerhalb des flughafen sie arbeiten in
der gastronomie sie arbeiten in der
logistik sie arbeiten in den
verkehrsdienstleistungen und das heißt
wenn wir sie heute zurück gewinnen
würden was wäre denn dann würden sie
genau an dieser stelle fehlen und das
ist ein zusammenhang der müssen sie mal
durchdenken 1&1 in dieser gesellschaft
bleibt auch immer noch eins um
und wenn sie denn einen aus dem einen
arbeitsplatz wegnehmen und in den
anderen geben dann fehlte halt einem
anderen arbeitsplatz und jetzt will ich
ihnen mal eins sagen frau klöckner der
kollege lange hat ja
lustigerweise in das ganze thema
arbeitsmarkt und sozialpolitik
ausgespart wahrscheinlich nicht ohne
grund denn im jahr 2009 gehört er auf
dem ausschuss für arbeit und soziales an
und in dieser legislaturperiode war es
die union arbeitsministerin ursula von
der leyen die den fachkräftemangel als
die große herausforderung unserer
gesellschaft bezeichnet habe und dann
gab es eine fdp damals mit in der
koalition die die ministerin dabei
unterstützt hat ein modernes
einwanderungsgesetz auf den weg zu
bringen und dann war es die csu damals
die gesagt hat nein das wollen bin ich
nämlich kein einwanderungsland sein und
dann ist der teil der cdu fraktion der
cdu in die ackerfurche verschwunden oder
hat gesagt naja da machen wir auch nicht
mit wenn die csu nicht will das ist die
wahrheit die kollegen kollegen dass uns
die geschichtliche wahrheit des dilemmas
das wir heute haben und dann haben sie
aber auch in späteren jahren nichts
gelernt 2009 10 haben sie ein gesetz
verabschiedet gegen den fachkräftemangel
in denen sie in der gesetzesbegründung
hineingeschrieben haben dass sie damit
rechnen dass 25.000 menschen neu in
unseren arbeitsmarkt kommen würden
obwohl damals experten schon gesagt
haben dass es 250.000 minimum pro jahr
sein müssten das heißt auch noch 2009 10
hatten sie nichts gelernt und dabei ist
demografie das voraussagt passte
überhaupt in unserer gesellschaft liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der union des
gerichts chaos sie sollten sich das
chaos an den flughäfen beseitigen wollen
sie sollten das chaos in ihrer eigenen
politik beseitigen und dann könnten wir
gemeinsam lösungen finden mittlerweile
werden wir bis sie sich sortiert habe
die verantwortung in diesem land
weiterhin überzeugend und erfolgreich
übernehmen vielen dank
und der letzte redner in der debatte ist
der kollege stefan schmidt bündnis
90/die grünen und stefan schmidt ist der
tourismuspolitische sprecher der
bündnisgrünen sehr geehrte frau
vorsitzende sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen die deutschen haben sehr große
lust urlaub zu machen und auch urlaub zu
buchen so zitiere ich einen
sachverständigen aus der anhörung im
tourismusausschuss vor einem vierteljahr
seit vielen monaten weiß die branche von
der großen reiselust nach zwei harten
corona jahren seit vielen monaten
schlägt sich das auch in den
buchungszahlen nieder die
luftverkehrsbranche hat sich also sehr
gut hätte sich sehr gut auf die
hoffnungsfrohe situation vorbereiten
können das hat sie nicht getan im
gegenteil sie hat während der pandemie
massenhaft personal entlassen die
menschen nicht mit attraktiven
arbeitsbedingungen wieder zurückgeholt
das flughafen chaos ist in erster linie
kein politisches versagen sondern
hausgemacht
trotzdem
trotzdem ist für uns klar und ich hoffe
dass auch herr lange das mitbekommen hat
wir greifen der branche und insbesondere
den fluggästen unter die arme die
bundesregierung hat kurzfristig
maßnahmen beschlossen um schnell
zusätzliche arbeitskräfte
bereitzustellen und damit die situation
an den flughäfen zu entspannen die
großen leidtragenden sind aber die die
am wenigsten für die situation können
nämlich die fluggäste sie statten
gestresst viel zu spät oder erst gar
nicht in den wohlverdienten urlaub sie
werden für den ausgefallenen flug häufig
nicht mal entschädigt obwohl airlines
dazu verpflichtet sind wir werden die
fluggastrechte stärken und die
entschädigungszahlungen automatisieren
das haben wir auch als ampel im
koalitionsvertrag verankert
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
fachkräftemangel ist ein riesenproblem
seit vielen jahren verschärft durch
corona wenn die cdu/csu jetzt nach ein
paar monaten opposition auf die idee
kommt ein sofortprogramm dafür zu
fordern dann kaufte ihnen das niemand ab
uns in der ampel ist die fachkräfte
förderung und sicherung besonders
wichtig das haben wir auch im kabinett
in den eckpunkten zur nationalen
tourismus strategie formuliert und
mittagessen im kabinett beschlossen die
ampel regierung geht die politischen
hausaufgaben an die union in den letzten
jahr 60 als das nicht gemacht hat und
wir gehen dabei weit über das hinaus was
sie fordern vielen dank und die fünf
euro fürs phrasenschwein kriegen sie
natürlich
[Applaus]
wir möchten gerne in der debatte weiter
wovon das können sie gern hinterher noch
klären aber wir wollen gern auch hier
vorankommen wir kommen nämlich jetzt zur
abstimmung über den antrag der fraktion
der cdu/csu auf drucksache 25
63 mit dem titel chaos an den flughäfen
beseitigen und sofortprogramm zur
arbeits und fachkräftegewinnung auflegen
wer stimmt für diesen antrag
das ist die unionsfraktion wer stimmt
dagegen
dass die fraktion die linke die
ampelkoalition wäre enthält sich dass
die fdp-fraktion der antrag ist damit
abgelehnt